Here,
here's the practical bit of information
for you to,
for all of you antisocial types who are
going to end up in prison.
So if you're in prison and you want to
go on parole,
okay,
so you have to go in front of the judge
and tell them why you're not going to do
it again.
So here's the deal.
Here's the deal.
It doesn't really matter what you did
and it doesn't really matter what you
promise.
What matters is whether you see the
judge before lunch or after lunch,
because if you see the judge after
lunch,
the probability that you will get parole
is 60 percent higher.
Yeah,
right.
That is just like so.
Never have an argument with your partner
when you're hungry or when they're
hungry.
Especially if you want something from
them.
It's like,
here's the sandwich.
They'll eat it,
then there'll be happy.
Then you can manipulate them before,
before that,
man,
no.